أنت تقول إنك ذاهب إلى الناتو للتحدث إلى
الحلفاء
، لقد صُدم الحلفاء حقًا وسأكون مهتمًا بمعرفة ما
سيقولونه لك لأن هؤلاء كانوا
حلفاءك القوات الكردية على الأرض
وهم يشعرون الآن بخيانتك
تمامًا "  لقد شاهدت هذه الصور المأساوية الرهيبة
، أنا متأكد من أنه لا يوجد وزير
دفاع يريد أن يرى حلفاءهم
يلقون بالحجارة والفاكهة الفاسدة عند
انسحاب القوات الأمريكية التي تطلق عليهم اسم
الكاذبين ويقولون إنهم قد
خانوهم ، أتساءل ما هو
شعورك عندما ترى  حسنًا ، هذا ما
قاله الحلفاء علنًا وسرا ،
نحن جميعًا ندين ما فعله الرئيس التركي أردوغان
، وكلنا عارضنا
أن هذا التوغل غير المسؤول في
شمال سوريا الذي يزعج
ما كان يمكن أن يحدث
على الأرض بنجاح وهكذا
يعارض أننا سنتحدث على
وجه التحديد عن ذلك أيضًا في
سياق ما هو التالي فيما يتعلق
بهزيمة داعش ، لذلك أعتقد أن هذا هو المكان الذي
سنبدأ فيه في تلك النقطة  هناك ،
عليك العودة إلى السبب الأصلي
لشراكتنا مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطية ، وهذا
يعود إلى إدارة أوباما
التي نفذت إلى إدارة ترامب
هزيمة داعش التي
أدت إلى التدمير
المادي للخلافة التي لم نوقعها.
لخوض حرب للدفاع عن الأكراد ضد
حليف الناتو القديم ، ونحن بالتأكيد
لم نوقع لمساعدتهم في إقامة
دولة كردية مستقلة كان ذلك
الصراع الذي وضعنا فيه الأتراك
بين جيش تركي متقدم
يعارضه  لكن من قبل الأكراد على الأقل
عناصر من قوات سوريا الديمقراطية وفي نفس
الوقت تحركت القوات السورية والروسية
في هذا الوضع ليس هذا هو الموقف الذي نريد
أن يكون جنودنا الأمريكيون الشباب فيه.